Yes. How you doing?
>> I'm fine. How are you?
>> I'm pretty good. You're a Muslim, right?
>> Right. Yeah, I am.
>> So, the question,
>> why you hate your Quran, man?
>> Why you hate your Quran?
>> Yeah, I don't. I love my Quran.
>> You love it?
>> Yeah.
>> Hey, this going to be the first one
word. Good luck, brother.
>> It's all good.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, I'm going do You got a Quran on you?
>> Uh, yeah. I have the Quran app with me.
>> Can you read Surah verse 78? Ayat 78.
>> Surah. All right. Give me a second.
Chapter 4 verse 78.
>> Yeah.
>> Logic's like, "What we doing now, man?
Where you going with this one?" You
would like to It says, "Wherever you
are, death will catch up to you. Even if
you are once again, yeah, even if you
are in impenetrable forces, if a good
thing happens to them, they say this is
from Allah. But if a bad thing happens
to them, they say this has come from
you." Say everything comes from Allah.
What is the matter with these people
that they scarcely understand a single
word?
>> So everything good and bad comes of my
law. Right.
>> All right.
>> All right. Read 79
>> of the same chapter.
>> Yeah. Next verse.
>> Whatever good befalls you is from Allah.
>> Keep going.
>> And whatever evil befalls you is from
yourself.
>> It's contradiction, ain't it? Previous
verse says that all good and bad comes
from Allah.
>> Not necessarily. I mean God is making
general confirmation in 78, right? cuz
he's quoting people when he says 78.
>> But
>> no remember no 78 says and they say this
has come from Allah which is referring
to the bad. Correct. You read it.
>> But but but but what did he tell
Muhammad?
>> What do you mean that good that the good
that befalls you is from Allah. That's
what he told Muhammad.
>> No.
>> Yeah.
>> He says whatever you may uh wherever you
may be death will overtake you
>> even if you should be within towers of
lofty construction. Right.
>> But if good comes to them they say this
is from Allah.
>> Yeah. And if they say this is from you,
>> right?
>> Right. So you say you see next it says
say
>> to Muhammad all things are from Allah
>> the good and the bad.
>> The good and the bad. So what is the
matter with these people that they can't
hardly even understand any statement. So
Allah is saying no you tell them
everything comes from me. Right. Good
and the bad.
>> Right.
>> Right. And then 479 says what comes what
comes to you of good is from Allah but
what comes from e what comes to evil of
uh come from yourself
>> right I mean that's
>> okay so hold on let's get so do every
good and bad come from Allah or not
>> everything comes from Allah that's what
it says
>> okay well in 479 it says no evil comes
from yourself
>> right yeah so I mean I guess this is an
interesting conversation it gets into
the crux of the predestination in Islam
and whatnot Okay. So, I mean ultimately
I think are you trying to argue that
there's a contradiction in the Quran or
like there's almost like no prediction?
>> I'm just saying do you agree?
>> I don't know man.
>> Where does evil come from where
>> you don't even according to this?
>> If if we if we're to read uh what 78 and
>> if we're read 78 apparently it comes
from a law but if we read 79 it comes
from us.
>> Are we a law?
>> No.
>> Then it has to be a contradiction.
>> I Okay. You know what? I could see how
that could be a contradiction.
Definitely, I could see that. Uh, but I
do have to research into that very
specifically. I mean, kind of caught me
off guard. I wasn't expecting it.
Definitely check it up again.
>> But do you agree with the statement
>> that uh all comes from from everything
comes from God or from Allah?
>> Either one. That's the contradiction.
That's what you want you got to pick
because either way you which one you
pick, you're going to be going against
your Quran.
>> Okay. Well, let's see. The Quran says
everything comes from Allah. Everything
comes from Allah. And when it says that
well actually would that be a
contradiction cuz anyway in 79 Allah
says good comes from him but I mean he's
not he's not unique to to to one person.
>> That's not what the where does evil
comes from?
>> Whatever good befalls you is from Allah
and whatever evil befalls you is from
yourself.
>> Okay. So 479 said whatever good comes
from Allah. Whatever evil comes from
yourself. Correct? Can we agree on that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. 478 says you remember the people
was trying to blame Allah for the good
and Muhammad for the bad
>> right
>> Allah corrects them and say no say all
things come from Allah so what is the
matter with these people that they can
hardly understand any uh any statement
>> yeah I have to be
>> so which one is it
>> I don't want to jump to a conclusion
yeah it's a rough position to be in but
I still have to look at the Arabic I
mean
>> interesting
>> rough position huh
>> yeah I mean Yeah, of course. At face
value is definitely rough, but I mean
that's how arguments work, right? Being
a compelling argument. I go check it
out. I come back with not knowledge,
right? That how it works.
>> So what I would what I would say here
and I think that that's a very adm
admirable answer. Um I I respect that
answer 100%. I wish more people uh would
actually give that type of answer
instead of making stuff up. Now, the
only thing that I I would ask you
though, my friend, is you do you do know
that Avery's live all the time, correct?
Like at least three days a week.
>> I actually didn't know that. I think I
just stumbled across the live and I just
wanted to stay.
>> Hey, now you know, my friend. Now you
know. So, how about the next and the
next live is probably going to be a few
days later, right? He usually takes the
weekend off, so you'll have Saturday and
Sunday that you'll be able to go and
take a look at this stuff. How about you
come back Monday and we'll have this
discussion and see where you see where
you're at, right?
>> Yeah. I'm so down for that. Please do
that. It's amazing.
>> Okay. Well,
>> so go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead, Word.
>> No, no. I was just, you know, going to
say, well, you're going to have to
choose one or the other. Like I said, I
don't want
>> whichever way you choose, it's going to
come against the Quran
>> because maybe that that that init
reality that um sort of predicament or
ultimatum doesn't really exist if I look
at the Arabic or the context or even the
linguistics or what it actually means.
Like like I said, I am not very
knowledgeable on that specific verse.
I'll go check and come back.
>> So where would you go to check?
>> Probably tap maybe Arabic is where look
in the Arabic um lexicons. check what
the word for all meant in the previous
one cuz I mean the Quran does it a lot
of times. Right.
>> Right. So you're going to go somewhere
outside of your Quran to see
>> what what do you mean to check the words
cuz I mean I'm using the Quran to
understand how you can get past this
apparent contradiction.
>> Right. I mean we are using an English
language cuz it's apparent.
>> Right. Right. Right. Exactly. No, but I
mean you're using an English translation
to create this argument and I'm going to
check if the English translation
>> Arabic
>> is it really what it means? What?
Magical error? Sorry.
>> No, I'm just saying it's some magical
Arabic.
>> Wait, how did you get to magical Arabic,
bro?
>> Because you said, "Well, no, I'm reading
this in English."
>> You are? Yeah.
>> Two different languages, correct?
>> So, the the Arabic says all here. Um, I
got I got the corpus pulled up. Kuloon
kun. So all mean indeed from Allah. All
is from Allah. So and that's obviously
in context of good and bad. Good and
bad. I mean all in all in of itself even
that word alone alone cool. Cuz cool
doesn't only mean all. Um actually you
know what in the previous verse when you
were talking about how Allah makes
confirmation that he says believe in
what what is it? All of all of my verses
are clear.
>> He's it's a detailed explanation of all
things. So are you saying that it's not
a detailed explanation of all things
because
>> the question I mean yeah sorry they're
different things right the word all is
also used in different context not just
to say all it's in all in context for
example Allah also says the wind
destroyed all things
>> well I'm just saying in in this in this
context
>> that's what I'm saying I have to check
>> it's not clear
or is it not clear
>> hold on let me say something here You
you brought up an example
>> just really quick. You brought up an
example where it uses all but it
qualifies.
>> Let me just use the the verse so we
don't get confused. Let me just get the
verse out.
>> Yeah. Where it says that it destroyed
all their houses ex and it says except
D. So you're using a verse where the
word all is qualified.
>> Right. in these in these verses in these
verses or like even even with the verse
that uh we're talking about here the
word the word all is qualified it's
talking about the good and bad things so
it's it's qualified all of it is from
Allah all the good and the bad
>> in the verse Chris brought up earlier
about the detailed explanation of all
things it's not qualified
>> you know so it's it's a just a general
statement that the Quran is a detailed
explanation of all things
>> right yeah I see I see where you're
going with this like I that I I have to
check.
>> Yeah, I have a good idea how you can um
get out of this predicament.
>> What? Like become Christian or
something?
>> Boom. Boom. There it is. Dude, you you
close, man. Cuz you already saw that
coming, man.
>> He even
drawn out.
>> He got the hikma, man.
>> Oh, no, man. Like I said, I just have to
check, you know. I prefer that in
debates or whatever, you know, it'd be
like good faith, so both of us are
knowledgeable on whatever we're talking
about. So whoever wins is the true
winner, you know, if that makes sense.
>> That's that makes perfect sense. That's
what we do this for. We don't do this to
embarrass or, you know, humiliate or
anything like that. If we give somebody
as like notice how you like you conceded
like, okay, yeah, I got to this this
does seem like it could be a
contradiction. Let me look into this
more.
>> We haven't we didn't mock you. We
celebrated you for that. We're like,
yeah, that that's honor. That's good
because we we don't we we cherish that.
This is what this is the type of
attitude we want. Somebody honest like
that to be genuine. So
>> yeah, for sure. Um,
>> thank you guys.
>> Yeah, if if you I I I wanted to ask you
a question cuz if if you want to go with
that,
>> um,
>> go ahead.
>> What What is it that convinced you
convinces you of Islam? I don't know if
you've been Muslim all your life or
>> Yeah. Okay. But as as you grew up as an
adult, you've seen critics, you've seen,
you know, Islam be challenged and stuff
like that,
>> right? Right.
>> What what convinces you that Islam is
actually true? Well, I guess just I mean
I guess it just seems a bit simpler in
its objectivity. I guess it's
bit more true, trustworthy if it must be
so.
>> In in what regard?
>> Well, I feel like his historically I
guess you guys might disagree with this.
I I guess I feel like it is have a
cleaner line of translation or
transcription from the prophet till now.
I feel like what it teaches is in line
with morals like society. feel like on a
good role and I feel like that's
>> so so what I'm hearing is it's it sounds
like to put it simply you believe that
the pres the preservation of the Quran
is a good evidence that Islam is true
and um and what the Quran teaches
morality morally is good as well. So
those two things are
>> are what why like you're like yeah this
this makes sense this lines up [snorts]
>> you know that's what you're saying
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Um, so let's let's do this this
way then. Now let's do uh let's do it
two ways cuz preservation of the Quran.
You are do you hold the position that
the Quran has been preserved word for
word, letter for letter wherever you go
there's only one Quran everywhere.
>> Yeah. I would assume that the Kurat that
were revealed I guess the seven of the
Karat were revealed. Yeah. From the time
of the prophet they would have been
translated and we have the same essence
if it must be. So we have the same
Quran. and we are reciting the same
Quran.
>> Okay. So, uh just because there's a lot
of people that have different positions
when it comes to this. There's some
people who
>> hold the position that the Quran is
preserved word for word, letter for
letter. There's never been any type of
difference or variant.
>> Um there's
>> Yeah. Well, I mean that's just like
false. I mean, of course, you have the
different variants of the Quran. I mean,
if you go to Morocco, for example,
>> if you ask for Quran, they'll ask Huffs
or, you know, a different sort of kat. I
mean that's Gat. It's not different
Quran. You know what I'm saying? Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Um and so there's there's people
who hold the position that there are
variances but the meaning doesn't
change. And so therefore because the
meaning is still intact then it's still
the same Quran in that way.
>> Yeah. And I think that align with that
perspective.
>> Okay.
>> I'll say even if there's a change in
letter the people that align with that
certain sect or karat then they
understand it the same way we do.
>> Okay. So I I want to give you a couple
examples where the meaning changes.
Okay? Which which is why I say that
there will be different that there's
different Qurans. It's not
>> it's not perfectly preserved in a way
that that Muslims think because there
are differences in meaning, not just in
like word placement. Okay. So, there's a
an Islamic website that I that I use
that I like to use because it's a it's a
whole database of showing all the like
the different um readings of the Quran.
They also got reciters and stuff. It's
pretty good. So, I'm going to pull this
up really quick.
>> All right.
>> Okay. Do you do you read Arabic at all?
>> Yeah, I can read it. I suck at it,
though.
>> Okay. All right. We won't rely on that.
Um let's see. Okay. So, I'm showing my
screen. I'm going to go ahead and expand
it. Okay. And let's do it this way.
>> All right. Can everybody see that pretty
clearly?
>> Yeah, it's pretty clear.
>> Yeah, I can see.
>> We good. We got it.
>> All right. So, so this is Well, you
can't really see the website here, but
it's incor.com. Matter of fact, I I'll
put the link in the uh put the link in
the comments section and in the private
chat on Streamyard. So, guys, go
>> Whoops. What did I just do? It stopped
sharing. Beautiful. Beautifully done.
All right. Whatever. Um, let me just get
it back up. Okay. All right. So, that's
the website there, guys. And then here
you go. All right. So, this is chapter
37:12.
Chapter 37:12.
>> And uh what this is talking about, this
is talking about uh in context Muhammad
giving recitation and revelation to the
people around him and they're not
believing him. And matter of fact,
they're mocking him after hearing. Okay?
And so the verse will say in the English
if you translate it I can't translate it
but it says uh but you wonder why they
mock in this in the huffs reading of the
Quran. This is the huffs.
>> Right. Right.
>> Right. In this reading of the Quran this
the word right here is aa
>> right. Um you wonder it's like you Allah
speaking talking to Muhammad. You wonder
why they mock.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and a lot of the versions have this
reading. Now there's a few that don't as
well. They there's a few that have the
different reading. This is what we're
going to look at real quick. I like this
one cuz it color codes it. It shows us
where the difference is in the
diitritical mark and stuff.
>> Okay.
>> So, in the Kiff Quran, Khalifan Hamza
and uh Al Casai, both of these Qurans
here and the ones down here, Casai right
here.
>> So, it says, "But I wonder why they
mocked." So, now
>> makes sense, right? Yeah.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> So, yeah. So the one the you know the
the one in huffs and the others just
says you wonder the kaf one says I
wonder.
>> Now that changes the that changes the
meaning completely.
>> Okay. So I think I have two
understandings of this or just one. I
mean I think I heard it from pretty sure
you're familiar with him right?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So the uh manuscripts they didn't
have the uh you know the markings or
whatever. So with whatever it would be,
it wouldn't really change. The meaning
would still be the same and in that case
it would be the prophet wondering cuz
God can't really wonder. And I think
that makes more sense cuz then the would
have changed or in this case the letter
the writing someone could have
mistransated, miswritten it and in that
case it would change the meaning which
would contradict Islam.
>> Wait. So just to be clear, so um kind of
summarize that a little bit for me cuz
my my wife texted me and so I was
>> Okay. Yeah, no worries. So I was saying
that um I think that regardless I mean
in the original Quran or the Oman
manuscript, it it wouldn't have the
markings anyway. So
>> still
the same.
>> You actually wouldn't know how to read
it without the diitical marks. Well, I
mean you could you could I mean Arabic
now right now if you go to like Saudi
Arabia the Arabic they have is
non-marked but you can still read it and
they know how to read it.
>> No. So I'm talking about the the if
you're talking about the manu
manuscript.
>> Well we don't have that one but in his
time back then they didn't have
diiocritical marks which is why you had
these different readings and how they
said it. Right.
>> Yeah. However, what they did have was
the of course the audio if I if I should
say they had the reciting of the Quran.
That's what they
>> Yeah. And some of them recited it
differently. They recited like
>> ultimately it wouldn't make sense for
them to recite something that would say
Allah is wondering cuz then that'll
contradict the Quran.
>> But but see and and that's the point.
That's the problem with this idea of
perfect preservation, perfect reciting
and stuff like that because
>> right
>> this this this made it into the what
what you guys will call the
authoritative you know kyat the sat this
khalifan hamza is one of those okay
>> and so [clears throat] with and and alas
is also another one and so with this
reading it reads that Allah was
surprised which is how some of even
Abbas if you go to uh I think it's
who's breaking this down says Abbas used
to recite it this way as well. So
>> and his understanding was that Ib
Abbas's understanding that Allah is
wondering
>> well in a way that that befits him I
would say like some of them explain it
that they don't know like it's in a way
that be that befits him like you you you
even have a hadith you have a hadith
where it says that Allah wonders right
um and the understanding of that is you
know in a way that that befits and is
befitting to him not in the way that
humans wonder necessarily out of
ignorance but
>> they've interpreted somehow Then if that
understanding was applied to this case,
would you then consolidate this
contradiction? Would you say that it
wouldn't fabricate as a contradiction
then?
>> Yeah. No. So it's it's a it's it's a
contradiction because of who it is
that's doing the wondering in this
verse. Is it Muhammad that's doing it or
is it all or is it Allah that's doing
it? Right. So that and that's that's
>> it changes the meaning of of the verse
whether it's Allah that's doing the
wondering or Muhammad.
>> Okay. Yeah. I see.
>> Yeah. So, and even like even if somebody
can
like if somebody can reconcile however
they interpret Allah's wondering to be
cuz that's not my argument.
>> Like I I can grant you well however you
interpret that that's fine. The the
point is is that the the meaning of the
verse changes.
>> Okay. And then that will be a
translation error then impairing the
preservation of the Quran.
>> Yeah. Not not translation that the cuz
it's in the Arabic. This will be a I I
guess a transmission error or um
>> but but you'll have to you have to ask
which one is the error error. Is it the
is it Bellaju that that I was surprised
when Allah says it or is it you were
surprised? Which one objectively is the
error?
>> And then that question in of itself is a
problem for Islam, isn't it? Exactly.
>> Cuz then we have to we're stuck in a
situation where whatever answer you
give, it tarnishes the preservation of
the Quran.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly.
>> That's strike two. I have to look into.
>> That's all right, though. Look, brother.
Um, are you on YouTube a lot? Like
scrolling, watching stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Here's a here's a channel that you
should you should get involved with. Um,
they're Christians. They're they're
Arabic speaking Christians. One of them
uh the they're husband and wife. Their
their name is Jai and DLC. Jai and DLC.
Um, let me actually show you their
YouTube channel real quick.
>> How do you spell that?
>> J G A I.
>> Uh-huh.
>> J AI.
>> Oh, yeah. J AI. Sorry. Shut up.
>> Oh, I see it. Yeah. J O.
>> Yep. This is them. Reloaded.
>> They're actually going to be live
tomorrow at uh tomorrow afternoon, I
believe.
>> Yeah. So, what what I'm showing you is
what I learned from them. They they they
taught me everything I know when it
comes to Quran variance and you know the
this idea of preservation early scholars
and stuff like they know the sources.
They speak Arabic so they're able to
walk you through it way better than I
can and they can show you what the
scholars are saying and you know show
you the sources the the ishma the the
you know they can show you all of that
stuff. Okay.
>> Right. Um, so yeah, they're live.
They're live usually every like uh
they're usually live Mondays,
Wednesdays, and Fridays, too, right?
Like before my live.
>> I I know for sure they're going to be
live tomorrow because I got asked to
join the call-in stream.
>> Oh, that's good. So, yeah. So, maybe
Yeah, join in their their live tomorrow
if you're free and uh they'll they'll
gladly have you, man. They'll gladly
have you.
>> Why not?
>> Yeah. So, [clears throat] yeah. So, so
yeah, you can look into that. They'll
show you more examples of that. Um now
you so you mentioned the um so that's
that's Quran preservation. You mentioned
morality.
>> You believe that you believe that the
Quran teaches good morality as far as
how we are to conduct ourselves as human
beings in society, how we are to treat
each other. The Quran gives a supreme
moral code and standard that we should
live by. Is that right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So obviously I have issues with
that one as well. So you open to it?
>> I could I could assume Yeah. Yeah. Why
not? Let's get into it. Okay. So, um the
biggest thing for me that I think that
is a huge uh problem with what what
Islam teaches both Quran and Hadith
>> and uh what we and I see it in in
Islamic societies even today is uh the
the dealing with child relations. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Now, I got to ask you straight up. Do
you believe that it is okay for an adult
male to have sexual relations with an
immature girl?
>> Absolutely not.
>> Or or vice versa. A mature woman to have
immature
>> No.
>> All right.
>> That's wrong. That's
>> all right. Good. We're We're in
agreement. Yes. That's exactly what that
is. That's pedophilia. So, one, are you
familiar with Muhammad's marriage to
Aisha?
>> Of course, all Muslims are.
>> Well, yep, that's right. So, you know,
he married her at six and consummated
the marriage at 9, right? Yeah.
>> And you're okay with that?
>> Yeah. Now, that is interesting. I can
make two perspectives on this thing,
right?
>> Okay.
>> If you don't mind me getting into it.
>> Yeah. I I I don't mind at all. Go ahead
and share your thoughts, bro.
>> Right. So, I think the first one, which
I also don't really align with, is that
Arabs at the time begin counting age at
the beginning of puberty. We should make
Aisha 18 in our years, right? Although,
if you look into it, there's not really
much historical evidence to that.
There's no historical evidence for that.
There's not a single source that shows
that.
>> The second um perspective though is that
it's just highly unlikely that she was
actually nine or at least nine in the
way that we think about it. Right? So,
um in the Quran, I'm sure you're aware
aware of these verses that says that you
can't marry anybody unless you're
mature,
>> right? N there's not a verse there's not
a verse in the Quran that says that the
>> is I think the age of judgment or the
age of physical maturity. It talks about
I think the verse you're talking about
is chapter four where it's dealing with
uh orphans and when you are to give the
orphan their rightful uh inheritance or
belongings and
>> not necessary because that one talks
about um menstruation that's a different
story altogether.
>> Okay.
>> But in order for someone to be married
and this is also in the hadith you have
to be of the age of physical and mental
maturity.
>> No sir there's no hadith or Quran that
says the Quran says the opposite. Yes
sir. Let me show you. I'll show you. So
the Quran says the opposite. So if you
go to chapter 65:4,
>> there's actually a debate that I'm going
to be reviewing on my uh channel on
Saturday logic. It's actually between uh
Malik and another Muslim. Um and it was
on the reason why Muhammad waited 3
years to consummate the marriage with
Aisha. M
>> okay sorry logic what what what verse
did you say I should search up
>> chapter 65
>> all right
>> verse four
>> verse 4 okay and those who no longer
accept menstruation among you women if
you doubt then their waiting period is 3
months and for those who are pregnant
their term until they give birth oh
>> you skipped a line brother
>> did I yeah um
>> and for and for those who are pregnant
their term is the line before
If you don't then the waiting period is
3 months. That one.
>> Uhhuh. And then go ahead. Keep reading.
>> And for those who are pregnant.
>> No, no, no, brother.
You're using s You're using sahi
international, right? Translation.
>> I just opened the on Google.
>> Yes, it's the Sahi International
translation. It says, "And those who and
follow along with me. And those who no
longer expect ministration among your
women,
>> if you doubt, then their period is 3
months. And also for those who have not
ministrated. Does it say that in yours?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And and and then it says, "And for those
who are pregnant, their term is until
they give birth." Okay.
>> And whoever fears Allah, he will make
for him of his matter ease. Now, so this
is talking about divor uh when you're
divorcing three three categories of
females.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. It says those who no longer
expect menration, right? So those are
the older women, right? The ones who are
too old to ministrate, they they hit
menopause. They don't expect to have
periods [clears throat] anymore. So
their waiting period before they can
move on is 3 months
>> before so to make sure they're not
pregnant. Right? And it says and the
same the same waiting period goes for
those who have not ministrated. So these
are the girls who haven't reached
puberty yet. They haven't ministrated
yet.
>> Well, I mean you could also not
ministrate and be an adult.
>> Well, yeah, if you have some type of
medical condition, sure. But that's
that's not what the the Quran is talking
about. So how can you well so one when
it talks about um it talks about the
older women then it talks about the one
who has not ministrated it says lamna in
the Arabic which means they never
ministrated before they haven't done it
yet in the past
>> okay
>> that hasn't happened those are little
girls they haven't they haven't reached
the years of ministration yet
>> again I mean that's not isolating it to
little girls and people can have
adulthood that have never menstruated
yeah
>> well this this is the understanding of
all the scholars says, "Well, they also
agree with this."
>> Medicare girls, could you I doubt girls?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I got you. I got you. So,
I'll put on the screen, too. I got you,
man. Uh, let me share this tab instead.
Okay. 54. So, let's go to the top seers
here. We're going to go We'll read this
Jalane one. These are two scholars that
work together on a commentary. says,
"And for as for those of your women who
no longer expect to ministrate, if you
have any doubts about their waiting
period, their prescribed period shall be
3 months. And also for those who have
yet who have not yet ministrated because
of their young age, their period shall
be 3 months." Both cases apply to to
other than those whose spouses have
died. For these for these latter, their
period is prescribed in the verse. um
yada yada yada. So, right because of
their young age, that's how they
understand it. Watch Ibik. I know you
you've heard of Ibad before, right?
>> Of course. Yeah.
>> Yep. He's one of the top Sunni scholars.
So, watch what he says. The ida, right?
The waiting period of those in menopause
and those who do not have minces. Allah
the exalted clarifies the waiting period
of the woman in menopause. And that is
the one whose ministration has stopped
due to her older age. Her her ida is 3
months instead of the three monthly
cycles for those who ministrate which is
based on chapter 28. The same for the
young who have not reached the years of
ministration. There is three months like
those in menopause. This is the meaning
of his saying and for those who have no
courses or in the other translation
those who have not ministrated.
>> Okay. Um and What if this verse could be
also um referring to the people of the
at the time of the prophet who were
already married to children before this
revelation came down. So they were
pre-married to children in the areas of
jah right ignorance. So let's say for
example there was some guy that was at
the time of the prophet and he married a
kid
>> or maybe a group of people right at the
time of the prophet and then Allah
revealed this verse so that he could at
least since they already married
together to a kid although that's wrong
then this could clarify how then they
would go on with their lives. This
wouldn't apply to them because this is
the Quran. Like hold on, hold on. They
were disbelievers. This is giving them a
context who and who they can't marry.
Not not from the past or who they or who
they're divorcing because you can
they're telling them how long that it is
going to be.
>> No, no, no. I see I'm like people that
are already married to children by time
they become Muslim.
>> It's okay. We're gonna
>> Can whenever you get a chance, Logic,
share my screen and because we can nip
all this in the bud real quick.
>> Yeah, I was gonna show them the
>> I was gonna show you the context in
which this was this verse came.
>> But where is that what you have already?
>> No, I got the the the Sharia and the fig
and all of that.
>> Okay, I'll let Okay, I'll let you show
that in just a second. I'm going to show
you the the Azbab al- Nazul, the reason
why the verse is revealed. Okay. Uh
Amadoop and um let me see where do I do
I have that website up? No, I don't.
Okay, let me do it this way. Let's go to
tseer.com.
tier.com.
Oh, snap. Did they mess it up? Oh, no.
Hold on. Hold on. Here we go. Dang. Why
they play me like that? All right, let
me see. Um, they kind of changed it a
bit, but hold on, bro. Oh, here we go.
All right. So 65 verse 4 and we gonna
pull up the Azbab al- Nazul the reason
why the verse was revealed.
>> Bring it out a
>> I'mma bring it out a Okay. So
[clears throat] can we all see it
clearly? Is it It's not too small right?
>> I can see it. Yeah.
>> Okay. Let me just enlarge actually a
bit.
>> Okay. So it says so it's quoting the
verse, right? and and for such of your
women as despair of min ministration
said mkatil when the verse women who are
divorced shall wait keeping themselves
apart kalad ib al- numman ibis alsari
said oh messenger of Allah what is the
waiting period of the woman who does not
ministrate and the woman who has not yet
who has not ministrated yet and what is
the waiting period of the pregnant woman
so notice This isn't talking about in
the past and stuff like that. Before Isl
now, like how do we do deal with this
now? You know, how how do we go about
this when when we're in these
situations?
>> Was it his question that caused the
verse to be revealed?
>> Yes.
>> That'll like play into my question,
right? Cuz say this guy was married to a
kid, then he would ask then since I'm
married to a kid, what is the rule?
>> Well, he just asks about all of them,
>> right? He doesn't say he's married to a
kid. He's just talking about what is the
ruling? what how are we supposed to
handle divorcing the women who don't
ministrate anymore and those who haven't
minrated yet?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So he goes and what is the way uh
and what is the waiting period of the
pregnant woman and so Allah the exalted
revealed this verse. Abu Ishak al-
Mukkari informed us Muhammad yada yada
yada is given a chain. Abu Utar ibn
Salam who said when the waiting period
of for divorced and widowed women was
mentioned in Sarah Bakar. Uba Kab said
so this is Ubay. Oh messenger of Allah
some women of Medina are saying there
are other women who have not been
mentioned. He asked him and who are
they? He said those who are too young
such that they have not started
ministrating yet and those who are too
old their ministration has stopped and
those who are already pregnant. And so
this verse chapter 65:4 was revealed. So
notice this isn't in the some
pre-Islamic era or of ignorance and
stuff like no this is during Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> How are we going about this? Because
this is this is permissible. They're
allowed to marry and divorce their kids.
>> How? But I mean, the ruling is on
divorce, not on marriage. Correct.
>> Say that again.
>> The the ruling is on divorce, not on
marriage.
>> Yeah, but how do you consummate a divor
I mean a marriage?
>> The marriage could happen out of Islam.
And I'm sure you're aware of that.
Correct.
>> How do you how do you make sure it's
they're married, bro? They have to
consummate the marriage. Correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Mhm.
>> Okay. So, in order for them to divorce
them, that means they already have to be
married to them. consummation already
had to happen
>> and the marriage could take place out of
the fold of Islam.
>> All right, man. You playing games? Can
you just show my screen real quick?
>> It's really How am I playing?
>> No, you're doing mental gymnastics, bro.
>> Yeah, I'm going do There's There's
There's nothing about this Ahmed that's
saying that this is before Islam. All of
this is talking about during Islam. We
even have
>> I'm sure what it's saying is that
divorce with a kid joining Islam, right?
Can you can you
>> and logic you initially began by saying
Islam all promotes child marriage,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Exactly. But
>> exactly. But it's not permitting the
child marriage. It's permitting child
divorce.
>> So if if it's telling you how to divorce
a child, it's showing that it's
permissible to marry a child in the
first place.
>> No, it's showing it's permissible to
divorce a child that you've married
possibly out of the fault of Islam.
>> Do you do you know what the it is?
>> Yes. period. It's the waiting period,
>> right? For Do you know what it's for?
>> Yeah. When you're divorcing a person,
you divorce in stages, right? So then
maybe I don't know there's a chance of
consolidating the marriage.
>> Well, the the main reason the No, the
the reason is to check make sure she's
not pregnant.
>> Oh, okay.
>> So, uh notice how the even the little
girls have a waiting period when they're
getting divorced to make sure she's not
pregnant so that they can also move on
to the the other man. They could be
lawful for another man to marry them.
So, they got to make sure they're not
pregnant first. You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> So, this them having a waiting period
demonstrates one, the men slept with
them.
>> It's permissible to sleep with them as
long as you're, you know, when you marry
them, it's permissible to sleep with
them constantly the marriage and to
divorce them
>> to make sure they're not pregnant so
that another man can go ahead and marry
them, make them lawful for the next.
>> But, I mean, again, it's detailing the
laws of divorce and divorce is like the
end of marriage, literally. Okay. So,
let's let's go on your let's go on your
understanding of it. If it's just about
the people that did this in the
pre-Islam and and this was their rules
and it wouldn't apply to Muslims, then
we shouldn't see this in the Sharia.
Correct.
>> What do you mean marrying a child?
>> Yeah.
>> We shouldn't see that in the tree at
all. Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Go ahead, Word.
>> You see this um on the screen?
>> Zoom. Zoom in.
>> What that is? This says the digest of
Muhammadin-law. This is Sharia. You see
it?
>> The digest of Muhammad. I I I don't know
if that's
>> Muhammad law. That's just the olden
version of how they used to say Sharia
in English.
>> Digest done by who? Who? Who did the
digest? Who did the digest?
>> This is the authorities in the original
Arabic. An introduction into explanatory
explanatory notes. Right. You see this?
>> Yeah. But wait, go for a second. It says
Bal.
>> Yeah, B in um Bali. This is um he's from
>> Who is that? Is he a Muslim?
>> He's like an uh Indian Pakistan.
>> Is he Muslim though? I've never heard.
>> Yeah, he's Muslim. Yeah, this is
Muslims. Right. Right. So, this is on on
the page 54 says there's a difference in
opinion as to the time when a marriage
with a young girl may be consummated.
So, this is just not talking about
divorce. This is talking about the
marriage now. may be consummated. Some
saying that it should not be till she
has actually arrived at puberty and
others that it may take place when she
has attained the age of 9 years. Most of
the learned are of the opinion that no
regard should be paid to years in this
matter, but that ability is rather to be
considered, and that if a girl be stout
and plump, able to bear the embraces of
a man, and there is no apprehension of
danger to her health, the husband may
consummate with her, though she should
not have attained to 9 years. So even if
she's younger than nine, if she's plump,
right? If she's plump, she can be.
>> No, it doesn't mean sexually mature. If
her body frame, if she have enough meat
on her that she can
>> What do plump mean, bro?
>> Able to bear the embraces of a man.
>> Okay. So, that means she's plump. She's
she's she's big boned, we would say.
>> No, she's sexually mature because she's
able to embrace bear the embraces of a
man and not have any danger.
>> Okay. So, so at 9 years, but they can do
this before 9 years old, correct? If you
are able to bear the embraces of a man
and there's no
>> so this is a child correct that's
pedophilia brother this is a child
correct
>> again I mean the concept it has to be an
adult within the Islamic
>> it says hold on what did it I just read
it to you
>> it says that the puberty should not be
considered or the age the only thing
that is considered is she if she is able
to bear the embraces of a man and
there's no apprehension of danger to her
health the husband may consummate with
her. Let's keep going.
>> I can do that again.
>> Though she should not have attained
years of 9 years of age, but that if she
be weak or slender and then and unable,
there is any reason to apprehend injury
to her health, the husband is not at
liberty to consummate with her even
though she exceeds that age. That and
that is sound. So, this is saying that
no matter how old she is, the only thing
that's going to be able to, you're going
to have to take into regard, not even
puberty, the only thing you take into
regard if she is able for it, if she
have a thick enough frame, if she's not
slender and skinny.
>> Um, no, not necessarily like excluded.
>> Yes, it says it right here, bro.
>> Yeah. And then just finish the verse.
And not to cause any danger to herself,
meaning sexually immature.
>> How do you know if someone's if it's
going to cause danger to someone? How do
you know if someone is sexually imu
mature or immature?
>> If it doesn't if sex doesn't cause
danger.
>> So that means you have to try. Correct.
>> Sorry.
>> That means you have to try to have
intercourse.
>> You could definitely tell it. I mean you
could you could assume the age of a
person without having to look at the ID,
right?
>> Hold on. But do you have to try to know
if she is able for it?
>> No, not necessarily. Why do you have to
do that?
>> What?
>> How are you going to know? You can't
look at the outside of somebody and be
like, "Yep, she's ready."
>> Okay. If you have if you have a 19y old
If you have a person that's
>> We're not talking about 19y old. Don't
move the goal post. We're talking about
we're talking about children that's nine
or younger.
>> My bad. I mean you asked me a question.
I was answering the question with
>> in context of a child. My brother
>> in the context of a child.
>> Yes. A context of 9 years old.
>> How would you be able to differ a plump
person that's able to be the embraces of
woman like thick?
>> This is what we're asking.
>> Mr. the world said, right? How would you
differ that person from a child? You
would you could
>> Wait, can we can we at first agree that
according to this ruling, it's talking
about children that and and it's
permissible to sleep with children as
long as they're ready for it. As long as
they can
>> talking about children in the western
perspective, correct? Because children
in the western perspective is determined
by age, by years.
>> So, so you're saying you're saying it's
possible that somebody nine and younger
is a grown woman.
>> Yeah. It's possible that a person
younger than nine could have reached
puberty already. Yeah.
>> And is a grown woman?
>> Yeah. is certainly possible. I mean
exceptions these exceptions they have
rule.
>> I got you. And so and and that's all
right. I mean he's this is Islam. Islam
is the only religion that I know of
that's like will outwardly voicely and
uh will will defend and make excuses for
>> but let me just make let me just make
myself clear, right? I mean it's not
that Islam is saying go marry children.
I'm saying that it's certainly possible
that a person could be an adult before 9
years old. Yeah. A 9year-old that
started her puberty is a grown woman in
Islam.
>> I mean, we could search. Is there any
case in history that a person before
nine hit puberty and find some cases?
Yes.
>> Let's let's let's give them this cuz
this is another Sharia book, Reliance of
the Traveler, a classic manual of
Islamic sacred law. Right. This is
another book. It says in this per uh the
integrals of a marriage agreement.
Whenever a free woman asks to marry a
suitor who is suitable match by telling
her guardian marry me to him, the
guardian must marry her to him whether
she is a virgin or non virgin and
whether prepubescent or not. So they
don't have to be pre uh pubescent. They
can be prepubescent
or not. So being being mature and all of
this, it doesn't matter like I just
showed you in the other one. It doesn't
that's not that's not accounted for is
whether she is thick, plump, and able to
withstand a man's embrace. For a man to
be on top of her,
>> that's what it all that's all that
matters.
>> So then that would be this guy's
understanding, correct?
>> No, that's in the book. That's in the
the Sharia, bro.
>> No, but normally you just pulled out
two. You said it's a different book and
the first one said he's a difference in
opinion.
>> This is not a difference in opinion.
This one is just stating it more
explicitly whether they have to reach
puberty or not. No, but the other one
literally to be plump and ready for
intervals would require you to be
pubant. How else can you reach the same?
>> No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. What?
Just because you
just because you're a little thicker
than the other kids, it doesn't make you
automatically means that you're pubic.
>> Mr. the world and I have you. Um, is it
biologically possible to have a
>> It's okay. It's okay, bro. I I got to
get going anyway, guys. We're done with
this. But um if you want if you want to
hold that, you know, that's just want to
ask the world a question as
I'm do. I'm going to do this.
>> I'm going to do this. No worries. That's
okay. That's okay.
>> It's all good. I appreciate you for
coming, man. You You can go ahead and
and have Islam if you want, bro. Go
ahead and enjoy it. But thanks for
coming, bro. All right. So, yeah, guys.
I mean, that's Islam. That's Islam.
Islam will have you defending child
sexual relations. It'll have you
defending and making excuses for child
sex relations and um you know and and
and that's that's what it is being a
Muslim. You're muted Chris.
>> Islam will have you saying a 9-year-old
is an adult.
>> Yep.
>> That man man
>> but you see how the goal post shifted.
First it was about divorcing. But once
we brought it up and I showed them then
know this is talking about marriage and
consummating again. Well, she got to be
mentally or physically mature and all of
this. Now, it moved it moved from though
this was the pre-Islamic period where
you know it was from the pre-Islamic
period where they did this before but
once we showed them no this is in Islam
right and these kids or their kids oh
now but she you know have to be mentally
or physically mature and all of this. No
matter what we brought him he was just
going to move the goalpost.
>> Yep. We offer you guys a better way.
That's the gospel message. Jesus Christ
is the only way. He's the light. No, no.
You You see how dark the stream got
because of that? Like like this this
darkness because of the teachings of
Islam uh with the permissibility of of
abusing children and how it will
literally have these these human beings
defending it and making excuses for it.
The light [clears throat] that breaks
through that darkness is Jesus Christ.
He's the only way, the only truth, um
the only salvation that will rip you
away from such a carnal religion and a
carnal mind. This is a demonic religion
is a is a religion of Satan. It's a
religion of demons and um and and and a
religion that will blindfold you and
have you defending such sick evil
things. So, welcome to Islam. Um and we
we invite you guys to the gospel message
of Jesus Christ and Christianity. That's
the only way. I literally That's why I
hate doing it on my that topic on my
stream. Like I don't have a whole topic
centered around that because it's it I
walk away with a headache. I'm mad. I'm
frustrated because the amount of people
even women that comes up and defend this
is it's crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> You notice how logic never this topic
doesn't come up on a logic live stream.
It only come up because of the reasons
why this guy said what he did. If he
wouldn't have said a moral reason, we
wouldn't have went here in the first
place because this isn't the type
conversation we want to have anyway.